you guys play high school girls seeking
revenge very heathers vibes love you
guys and you guys are very much giving
me that glen rg from fatal attraction
how much fun was it to tap into these
characters
it's so much fun beyond fun 10 10 out of
10. 10 out of 10 would do again
awesome so jen robson the director has
dubbed the cast the young hollywood
avengers aka the revengers how honored
are you to be called that and recognized
for all of your work so honored i mean
like i think that jen is is so quippy
and smart and like comes up with such
good kind of fun names for things and i
feel like a big part of like i don't
know internet culture right now and like
is like deciding what something is like
if whatever someone's fan base is called
a name like that's like yeah i don't
know we like we we hate labels but we
love labels yeah
we love on the internet like you know
when you grab a bunch of people from the
same from different shows and put them
in the same thing and mix them together
yeah call it something
like the revengers
um so it's awesome
no definitely you guys are talking about
your iconic shows and like everyone
loves them so much and they're both on
the last seasons so what can you guys
tell us about riverdale and stranger
things like
have you guys started filming yet what
can you tease what can you say
i haven't started shooting riverdale
season seven yet but we will be going
back in october i believe so very soon
um and i have no idea what's to come i
don't i haven't read anything yet so
we'll see
no information
and i can't share any of the
non-information that i have are you guys
sure you can't tell me one more thing
i literally don't know any other things
and quickly let's talk about the fashion
movie it's giving me nostalgia vibes i
love it it's so bright and everything
what do you guys like most about the
outfits
kind of what you said it's like super
bright and dynamic and i feel like
each character had their own world and
their own vibe but also felt like they
were part of this larger cohesive world
um
and i i don't know every every look for
drea was sort of like an evolution of
like seeing her character
um at her you know her perceived
happiness
her perceived most happy to by the end
when she's fully lost it and unhinged
and seeing that evolution we were trying
to capture that through her
uh wardrobe
yeah all of illinois costumes in
different ways from the beginning to the
end really took me out of my comfort
zone and i think that
nicely eleanor was sort of almost never
in her comfort zone until like maybe the
very very end of the film
and so that was always felt kind of
right for the character um and i and i
got to experiment and play with like
looking a lot of different ways that i
don't normally so i really like that
awesome well that's all the time we have
thank you guys so much i really enjoyed
the movie thank you
you